evening my name is Officer Alexander
Cuevas that is
a-l-e-x-a-n-d-e-r-c-u-e-v-a-s I'm the
public information officer with the
north Las Vegas Police Department
tonight officers are investigating a
mass casualty traffic collision with at
least five casualties involved
so far this is involving six vehicles
and speed is a factor as for the initial
vehicle it is a Dodge Challenger that
was going northbound on Commerce
approaching Cheyenne at a high rate of
speed and with that it struck multiple
vehicles and unfortunately it was a
chaotic event there is more information
to be released as investigators further
their investigation into this incident
um
as for the initial call it did happen
just after 3 P.M
and unfortunately that is all the
information I do have at this time but
there will be more information later so
media Outlets will have access to the
scene as soon as the decedents are moved
so as for that is there any follow-up
questions
so right now this area between Cheyenne
Commerce there is massive road closures
we will probably be out here
for a lot more hours at this time
at this point uh from what Witnesses
have stated the initial vehicle did run
a red light
the age ranges of the decedents ranges
from Young juveniles to
middle-aged adults
and the person who caused the accident
that person also one of the ones who
died correct that is one of the
decedents
times six
six casualties yes at this time I can
confirm there is at least five
casualties but the total number will be
confirmed at a later time
all right thank you very much
um I'll keep you all updated on the next
press briefing